Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
Imagina una rueda de reconocimiento
donde se pide a diez testigos
que identifiquen a un ladrón de bancos
que vieron huir de la escena del crimen.
Si seis de ellos señalan
a la misma persona,
hay una buena probabilidad
de que esta sea culpable
si lo hacen las diez,
se podría pensar que el caso
no deja lugar a dudas
pero podrías equivocarte.
Para la mayoría, esto
suena bastante extraño.
Después de todo, gran parte de la sociedad
se basa en la mayoría y el consenso,
sea en política, en los negocios,
o en el entretenimiento.
Así que es normal que pienses
que más consenso es mejor.
Y hasta cierto punto,
normalmente lo es.
Pero, a veces, cuanto más cerca
se está de llegar a un acuerdo total,
menos confiable se vuelve el resultado.
Esto se conoce como
la paradoja de la unanimidad.
La clave para entender
esta aparente paradoja
está en considerar el nivel
general de incertidumbre
involucrado en el tipo de situación
con el que estás lidiando.
Si en una rueda de reconocimiento
se pide a testigos que identifiquen
la manzana por ejemplo,
no deberíamos sorprendernos
por oír un veredicto unánime.
Pero en los casos en los que
esperamos opiniones diversas
también deberíamos esperar
una distribución variada.
Si lanzas una moneda cien veces,
es de esperar que salga cara
la mitad de las veces.
Pero si tus resultados
se acercan a un 100 % de caras,
sospecharías que algo no va bien,
y no con cada tiro
sino con la moneda en sí.
Claro, identificar sospechosos no es
algo tan aleatorio como tirar una moneda,
pero tampoco es tan evidente como
separar las manzanas de las bananas.
De hecho, un estudio del año 1994
encontró que hasta un 48 % de los testigos
suele elegir la persona errónea
en una rueda de reconocimiento
incluso cuando la mayoría
está segura de su elección.
Los recuerdos basados en un vistazo
breve son poco fiables
y a menudo sobrestimamos
nuestra exactitud.
Sabiendo todo esto,
una identificación unánime empieza
a parecerse menos a culpabilidad,
y más a un error sistémico
o sesgo durante el reconocimiento.
Y los errores sistemáticos no implican
solo los sesgos en el juicio humano.
Entre 1993 a 2008
se encontró el mismo ADN femenino
en varias escenas del crimen en Europa,
culpando así a una escurridiza asesina
conocida como Fantasma de Heilbronn.
Pero el mismo ADN estaba presente
en todas las pruebas
porque los bastoncillos de algodón usados
para recolectar las muestras de ADN
fueron contaminados accidentalmente
por una operaria de la fábrica de algodón.
En otros casos, surgen errores
sistemáticos debido al fraude deliberado,
como el referendo presidencial celebrado
por Saddam Hussein en 2002,
en el que del 100 % de los votantes,
supuestamente el 100 % votó a favor
de otro mandato suyo de siete años.
Si la miramos de este modo,
la paradoja de la unanimidad
en realidad no es tan paradójica.
Una decisión unánime sigue siendo
un resultado ideal en teoría,
sobre todo en los casos donde hay
mucho consenso y poca incertidumbre,
pero en la práctica,
llegar a un acuerdo unánime
es muy poco probable
y debería indicar que quizá haya alguna
razón oculta que afecta al sistema.
Si bien podemos aspirar
a la armonía y el consenso,
debemos tener en cuenta a menudo
el error y el desacuerdo.
Y si un resultado unánime parece
demasiado bueno para ser verdad,
probablemente lo sea.